it looks like a toy it tastes like raw
bread dough oh it's an egg
oh it looks like an egg it looks like an
egg
what's up everybody it's your girl merle
and today we are going to be making a
vegan fried egg using squash
i know these things just continue to get
weirder doesn't this look like fish
i kind of wish i didn't see this like if
you took snow
and then you put chocolate on snow i
wouldn't eat that ever
but it's gonna be a lot of fun i think
this might actually be the most
challenging recipe vegan substitute
video i've done so far so i'm a little
nervous but i'm very excited at the
outcome because i think if i do it right
people are gonna freak out let's just
address a couple elephants in this room
no it will not be a real egg there's no
way for me to create an actual chicken
egg i'm not a chicken i'm not gonna be
laying an egg it's gonna be a vegan
version of an egg so once we get past
that the rest is gonna be really cool
secondly this is a labor-intensive
recipe i'm not suggesting that you make
this every morning because you would
drive yourself insane i want to know if
i can make a vegan egg and i want to see
if i can fool my coworkers or at least
impress them with my abilities
it's time to cook so the first step is
going to be to combine our kubota squash
with our other ingredients for the yolk
the kubota squash is going to give the
yolk its beautiful orange color and the
black salt is going to be a real true
ingredient that's going to bring this to
the next level it's very popular because
it smells oh man super gross actually
but it smells very sulfuric and when
it's added to dishes it gives that kind
of sulfuric eggy flavor i'm going to add
some canola oil and the fat from the
canola oil is going to sort of replicate
the fat that you would get in an actual
egg yolk which will keep it all together
and give us like a nice velvety texture
oh my god that's
black salt smells horrendous yikes
all of this is gonna have to come
together to get that egg like flavor oh
my god this is disgusting
all right let's blend this baby up
oh my gosh it tastes like a hard-boiled
egg cool
very excited about this
and so we're gonna cook this over a very
very low heat
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
make a cornstarch slurry which is going
to get us the texture we want mix you up
i'm going to add my cornstarch slurry to
my yolk mixture and then i am going to
whisk away
so we're gonna keep stirring and
stirring and stirring for like three or
four minutes
our mixture is ready so now i'm just
going to set this aside in a bowl and
let it refrigerate probably like 30
minutes or so
all right so while our yolks are cooling
down in the fridge it's time to make the
egg whites so i'm gonna combine
some coconut milk silken tofu some salt
and some water and then of course some
more of the black salt for even more of
the eggy taste here goes nothing
i'm just going to transfer this mixture
out and set it aside
all right
spoon these bad boys in there
i'm gonna refrigerate these for three
hours then we gotta try to put this
whole thing together
okay let's do it
so we have two of the completed solid
adorable little yolks here you can see
when you touch it there's like a little
bouncy fun time so i'm gonna plop some
of this in here
cool all right let's do this i'm gonna
put the yolk on there oh my god you're
so cute oh it looks like an egg it looks
like an egg
now i'm gonna cover it up and we're
gonna let it cook for like three or four
minutes and then it should be done
oh my god it's so cute
oh yeah wow
check that out oh it's so good
oh my god i'm so proud i hope it tastes
good
hmm it's a little sweet
i'm gonna put a little salt and pepper
on it and see if that helps
you know i like it i like the way it
tastes does it taste just like an egg no
no it doesn't the flavor is really good
but it's not super super super eggy i
think it's hard to like totally recreate
an egg yolk i'm happy i'm a little
confused but i'm also excited i'm
curious to see what people are going to
think this is when i give it to them
oh it's an egg
wow
what it's so cute
isn't it so cute this looks like a egg
yolk on top of a pancake it looks like a
toy this is so sweet look how much
effort went into this i love egg you
know uh
they're they're high in protein it looks
like you know what it is so when you go
to one of those uh what do you call it
those fancy places where they
restaurants
i haven't been to one of those in a
while many other did you have a date
i've heard that
we didn't go to a restaurant
oh actually yes we did
[Music]
are you ever gonna eat this egg i keep
stalling yeah i know explore
have some fun with it you're making me
nervous how you're talking yo
sorry
whoa
so what is that reaction it's not like a
runny egg but
it's like you just let it sit there for
a little while almost
delicious that is what i missed
from eggs uh have you ever had an egg
yes i have had many eggs
it's hard
literally
hard to recreate because it's like oh
yeah
would you just eat this egg just like
oh god
break it
this is good
wait what is this is it a sweet potato
like shredded wheat is this cauliflower
have you had a bite of this
yeah a couple oh that's sulfur shawarma
dough no certainly not
cornmeal carrot
squash it tastes like it's like
grits and eggs i'm using my palate
are you this is squash
yes it is squash one of these guys
oh what's fun i love kombucha squash my
favorite squash in the short time i've
known you you know i i think you're a
wonderful person if you gave me this i
would
i would say
thank you uh i would say
you look great
you look great at least i've got that
going for me it's from zero to egg what
would you give it from zero to egg i'm
gonna i'm like a scallop
i'm gonna give it like
what the hell was that seven point five
out of ten
that's up and down i thought you hated
it you told me to quit my job and go be
attractive
i did not say that in so many words and
it's like an adventure you're like
putting it in your mouth and you're like
what's what's going on in here am i
what planet is this from
like i said from zero to egg it's not
like
it's an egg but is it good
hell yeah do i need to finish eating
this i mean you have one last bite you
may as well
so you would like me to finish i'll eat
it if you don't
great great thank you so much
all right that's not real bread is it no
you got it
[Music]
you